كرواتيا تحرز الميداليه البرونزيه في كاس
العالم بعد الفوز على المغرب بهدفين لهدف
هي البرازيه الثانيه لكرواتيا في
المونديال بعد ما نجح في تحقيق المركز
الثالث في مونديال فرنسا عام 98 اسود
الاطلس قدموا ملحمه كرويه على ملاعب
المونديال لم ينعموا بخصم سهل او متوسط
بمقاييس وتصنيفات فيفا بل وقعوا في احد
اصعب المجموعات وتصدرها بعد الفوز على
بلجيكا كندا وتعادل مع كرواتيا في دوره 16
واجهه المتدور الاسباني يتفوقوا بركلات
الترجيح اجتازوا عقبه البرتغال ورونالدو
في 4 نهائي قبل ان يخسروا في نصف نهائي
امام حامل اللقب فرنسا بهدفين مقابل لا
شيء رغم الاداء الكبير المنتخب المغربي
ينجح في كتابه التاريخ في صفحات كاس
العالم ستبقى قصه اسود الاطلس خالده حكايه
رائعه تناقلها الاجيال في القاره السمراء
ومن المحيط الى الخليج النسخه الثانيه
والعشرين من كاس بعنوان المغاربه مروا من
هنا